hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in the course of his analyses of some of
the human emotions in rhetoric book 2
aristotle is going to draw a very
important distinction between two
different negative emotions that are
often mistaken for each other not only
in our own time but also back then and
so he's going to highlight a number of
differences between on the one side
anger
or gay in greek and on the other side
two different terms misos and ekthra
which we translate as hatred and misos
is you could say a little bit more is
just straight hatred extra
being hostile being an enemy but
aristotle is going to use them more or
less synonymously
in his discussions of these
and so
how do these emotions differ from each
other
aristotle tells us he begins by talking
about the causality
of hatred in this discussion and you
notice that
anger can be a cause of hatred but anger
has its own
causes or its own provocations right it
is produced by as aristotle tells us in
his definition of anger apparent or
public or imagined
sliding oleguria ways of treating
somebody as if they're of little or no
value or at least less value than they
would like to view themselves as or
treating
things that they identify with or care
about
hatred interestingly aristotle is going
to say can be produced by anger as a
matter of fact this is a
issue that aristotle himself doesn't
highlight that much but many other
thinkers who grapple with this
distinction between hatred and anger
caution us about telling us that there's
a tendency for anger if it's held on too
long or unresolved to
eventually turn into something deeper
like hatred
it's also produced by as he says spite
or spitefulness or malice
in greek which interestingly
is one of the three modes of sliding so
so hatred or anger can be produced by
spite what is spite it is setting up
obstacles problems impediments to people
just for the sake of doing that to mess
with them not to get anything else out
of it and then the third cause that he
tells us of
hatred that we don't see
happening on the side of anger is
slander diaboli
literally
uh selling
saying things that are bad about a
person
uh maligning them
in a way it could be public could be
behind their back and now that could
turn into a kind of sliding but
aristotle singles that out
here so we've got two different ways in
which these can be caused and anger
itself can be a cause
of hatred
another key distinction that aristotle
is going to make
has to do with
why we get angry
and
you know
the you could call it the individual's
centered uh perspective on it so anger
he tells us arises from acts against
oneself
he auton in in greek now we've seen that
in the definition it doesn't have to be
directly against oneself it could be
against those who one is concerned with
aristotle mentions parents and children
as and spouses as people that we ought
to defend
it could also extend to abstractions or
non-animate objects you know somebody
criticizes philosophy i can get angry
because i'm invested in philosophy
hatred can arise from those things so
you can feel hatred against somebody who
is doing things against you or your
family
or you know something else that you
identify with but it can also arise even
from acts that are not against the
person
involved it can arise in some respects
in a much wider environment right and
this brings us to the next really
important distinction
aristotle is going to tell us that anger
has individuals
as its object individuals is how we're
translating the
koth hekastone which generally we
translate as particulars right
individuals are a certain kind of
particulars and he mentions calius or
socrates so you get angry
not just with you know
people in general but with specific
things it could be people
it could be getting angry at the wind
for blowing on you when you don't like
it the sun for being too hot right
and
hatred is a little bit different in this
respect aristotle tells us
that hatred is against entire classes or
groups gainey
in greek
as its object so
the examples that he uses
are thieves um those who engage in
stealing like kleptase right and then he
also brings up informal informers uh
sucofontes the word that we get
psychophant from somebody who's always
like you know whispering in somebody's
ear did you hear that so-and-so did this
and that right
and
aristotle says we just hate those kind
of people in general we feel hatred
towards them typically maybe even people
who belong to those classes hate those
classes and we can think about all sorts
of other examples this could be based on
you know where you're from
geographically
what ethnicity you are
how race is identified it could be tied
in with gender it could be tied in
with social classes you know the enmity
of the rich for
the
poor and vice versa
it could be it could be you know
belonging to a different uh sports team
or a fandom or something like that but
it's not directed against an individual
per se it's directed against an
individual
as a member
of something as a token a stand-in
for that hated class
another very important uh
distinction between hatred and anger
is that anger as aristotle says at least
in some cases can be healed
with time chronos right so the uh
duration of time living through time
your anger very often unless you've got
some really significant anger problems
or it's being reawakened all the time
your anger will eventually dissipate
you'll let go of those things
aristotle says hatred
no cannot be healed by time you start
hating unless something changes
and not just the passage of time but
something in time like
realizing that you got things wrong and
you don't need to actually hate an
entire class of people or having some
sort of relevant experience
that gets you to see that this person is
an exception to the rule of your your
hatred against an entire group um
time itself is not going to heal
hatred something else has to come along
and do that
what is it that anger and hatred
actually aim at what is it that they're
after aristotle uh asks and
interestingly he tells us that anger
aims at the
pain lupe in greek of the other person
somebody hurts you
in some way could be you know physically
it could be status it could be in other
respects
you want to hurt them back you literally
want them to
suffer in return
or suffer
what it is
that
you yourself have been suffering the
greek word there is antipathane right
parthian is to suffer auntie in response
or with a certain kind of reciprocity so
that's that's what anger is is aiming at
hatred
goes deeper instead of just aiming at
pain which is a bad thing or an evil it
aims at doing evil to the other person
or evil happening to them the [ __ ] on in
in greek and it can extend to the point
where what you really really want
is the non-existence of what it is that
you hate that may ain't i in greek may
meaning not a ni being the verb to be
so when you hate people you would
actually like to see them eliminated
eradicated
put aside in some way cast outside of
the
social circles that you are in
very important distinction there
another important distinction anger
itself is not only aiming at imposing
pain on the other
it is accompanied by pain metal base and
this is right out of the definition of
anger
it's a
painful emotion to feel
and it's caused by some sort of pain due
to the apparent sliding
hatred aristotle tells us is not
accompanied by pain you can hate
and it doesn't feel bad per se
to hate another
person or rather
a token of an entire class
of people so this you know the fact that
um it can't be healed by time it's not
accompanied by pain means that hatred
is in some respects much more durable
than than anger
finally the the last
important distinction that we see being
made
the angry person can feel more than one
thing at the same time as a matter of
fact to be angry as we
see in the definition of anger already
involves feeling desire feeling pain
feeling pleasure but one might also feel
what we can translate as compassion
or pity here it's in the greek verb
elecin right
and this comes from aleos which means
pity or compassion with the other person
literally a feeling bad because of the
undeserved suffering happening to
another person and this is this is very
interesting aristotle doesn't follow
this up but you can be angry with
somebody
retaliating against them
and at the same time feeling bad
about the pain that they are suffering
pain that you yourself are desiring and
causing in them
nothing like that exists for hatred
aristotle thinks that the hating person
doesn't feel any compassion or pity for
the person who they desire evil or even
non-existence
uh to to happen to right
so these are some really important
dividing lines you could say on a number
of different aspects that tell us what
the difference between the emotion of
anger and the emotion of hatred
look like how we can
understand these within ourselves how we
can understand them in the working of
other people as i mentioned at the start
there is a tendency to blur these
together for many people in our own
culture to mistake anger for hatred or
vice versa aristotle thinks that it's
important
that we
maintain these distinct from each other
if we want to understand our own
emotions and those of other people
you